hi there today I'm going to talk about
why I learned languages I'm gonna do
that because at our forum there was a
thread started by one of our members at
link and basically he said you know what
is better modest quality or flashy
quantity and he sort of said you know
aren't you better to focus on one
language on learn it thoroughly rather
than trying to show off by sewing
speaking so many different languages so
I kind of felt like is he talking about
me
Korean would be my thirteenth language
obviously I could go back to Japanese I
would love to Japanese Chinese Spanish I
could do them in greater depth learn
more words get more deeply into the
culture and needless to say all the
other languages that I don't speak as
well as Japanese or Chinese or Spanish
so you know and I love listening to
French audiobooks so yeah that's always
the decision you have to make do I go
and and and enjoy the languages that
I've already learned or do I add a new
one before I get into my answer that
I'll just quickly run through my day
today
day 36 I was up early to see the end of
the Russia Finland game at the Sochi
Olympics a shocker and then Canada I
didn't see the game because I had to go
off and play hockey myself but I I
recorded the game between Canada and
Latvia and Canada just squeaked by
Latvia now in both cases you have a team
that's more talented struggling against
a team with less talent
although the Finns are pretty talented
team but still the Russians were favored
better and so forth and you know the
underdog was hungrier I think that was
the conclusion that I came away with
both the Finns were hungrier than the
Russians the Latvians were hungrier than
the Canadians but the Canadians managed
to squeak by so after my hockey I went
up to my Korean dry cleaner because I
had taken a sweater there last week so
we chatted a bit in Korean went to a
Japanese restaurant where there are
Koreans behind the counter I sat at the
counter we spoke some Korean I had my
iPad there I was reading beside a lady
who was an immigrant from Iran
and she was interested in the fact that
I could speak Korean and was reading in
Korean so we had a conversation she's
interested in learning languages I gave
her a card a link card hopefully she
shows up so while our languages why
learn em you know multiple languages all
right the reason I learn languages is
for the kinds of things that I'm now
starting to be able to do in Korean if I
listen to Kim Jung 'has podcast I don't
understand it much but I know roughly
what he's talking about but I'm enjoying
it and I and I am challenged by the fact
that I can eventually get to where I can
actually understand what it's saying
through this YouTube channel someone
pointed out to me that there is a TED TV
talk where Kim Yong Hwa speaks and there
is a transcript so with that I imported
into link and I've been studying it so I
learned I learned about Kim Jung ha who
is a Korean and in this TED talk he is
encouraging Koreans to be more creative
more playful become artists and he makes
reference to people like Flo BAE
Martha Graham who's I didn't even know
who she was but she's a world famous
dancer who visited Korea at the age of
90 and someone said to her you know what
advice do you have for Korean people who
are into modern dance and she said just
do it and that was Kim Jung Hwa's sort
of message to his Korean audience just
do it you know life is a game enjoy it
and so forth so to me it's a bit of a
game as well but more than that it
enables me to connect some of the items
that I've been studying there is one
Korean news item about they're gonna
change the address system in Seoul of
course reading Chosun Ilbo and the whole
issue of the relations between Japan and
Korea I hope to get into more history
these are the kinds of things that I
want to connect with with check you know
this tolki chess communal asti listening
to endless hours of
beautiful podcasts radio programs about
Czech history
you know Habsburg history Czech history
the Holy Roman Empire the role of Prague
in the 14th century all these kinds of
things Russian you know listening to
Russian audiobooks or
an even current affairs the activity in
Czech Ekho Moskvy in Russian so Panza
romanian while I never got very good at
Romanian I was able to start listening
to history podcasts or radio programs
news radio programs and that's it you
connect the goal is not like I could not
just you know do like how people swear
by a C mail or whatever I can't just do
you know hello how are you my name is
learn how to say all these things so
that you can say them you know yes it's
fun to be in a restaurant and chitchat
with a waiter but that's not the goal if
that were the the end purpose of
learning the language I wouldn't bother
so the fact that I now I'm much more
knowledgeable about Czech history
Russian history current events in those
countries
hopefully we'll start to do that in
Korean have some some sense of how
people there think have listened to them
talk in their own language that to me is
is the attraction sitting beside this
immigrant lady from Iran if I could
learn Farsi and when I think of Iran and
I think of Central Asia and you know
bukhara and you know the Silk Road and
and everything I'd love to learn Turkish
Arabic Farsi I don't know Hindi target
me just to get a flavor of what those
people and cultures are all about it's
not a matter of showing off no and so
it's not a matter of normally it's not a
matter of three months I have here a 90
day challenge where I I'm challenging
people to step up the level of their
intensity in terms of language learning
because I know intensity pays big
results big dividends but it's not you
know
see in three months look at me I speak
this language that's not the goal you
know Russian I was added for five years
listening listening listening check you
know a year in Psalm then I went away
from it then I was back at it again I
mean it takes time it takes time but
there's no reason why and but Romanian
wouldn't take as long in Romanian I was
only at it for two months I am sure that
in a much shorter period of time because
so much vocabulary is similar to to
Italian and so forth that it's easier so
you know Portuguese and Spanish the same
idea so the amount of time required
varies from language to language but it
does take a lot of time but the goal is
to achieve a depth so that you can
actually start learning the language
from again meaningful content and what's
meaningful to one person may not be
meaningful to another I'm not interested
in anime for example many people are and
that's their motivation for learning
Japanese so to me the reason I learn
languages is to connect with some aspect
of the culture history whatever of that
language the ability to speak with
people is a bonus but realistically five
years I'm here in my car listening to
audiobooks and Russian you know
political discussion in Russian or
inject and hopefully now in Korean how
much time I gonna spend us I spent a
total of ten days in Russia I spent
maybe another ten days in the Czech
Republic actually using the language so
the amount of time I spend using it is
actually quite limited compared to the
immense enjoyment that I have acquired
through my contact through reading and
listening to the language so in that
sense as you know the question of
whether you focus on one language or go
after ten it's entirely up to you what
are you interested in you know there's
so much more I could do in Chinese if I
wanted to and I would love to but I have
to make a choice I have only so much
time available so maybe you know rather
than learning Farsi and Arabic I may go
back and get deeper into Chinese